[Music]
if you think about where we get virtual
reality from there's something called
the flight simulator in 1929 Edwin link
said he didn't want to learn how to fly
from a book but flying a plane is very
expensive in terms of making a mistake
making a mistake in a plane people die
obviously planes get lost so Edward link
developed the flight simulator so people
could learn by doing in a safe
environment so one of the ways of
general public that people who aren't
just gamers or technologists are seeing
VRS and training so one thing I've done
for the last few years is I've used
virtual reality to Train athletes
project began as a master's thesis by
Derrick belch as a student at Stanford
we use virtual reality to Train
quarterbacks to look around recognize
the defensive pattern make a decision by
changing the play they can keep the
original play or they can kill kill kill
and go down to the next play in the
queue when Derrick graduated in 2015 he
founded a company called Stryver and
Stryver in the first six months signed
five NFL teams two multi-year contracts
about a dozen college teams and what
we've seen over the last few years is
many teams adapting using VR so that
players can get extra mental repetitions
now where this goes down to your
everyday person is the lessons that we
learned by training athletes it turns
out applies to just about every job so
think about your own job it you have to
look around you have to see stuff we
call this recognition pattern
recognition and then you have to make a
decision and then you have to
communicate that decision so for a
quarterback he looks around spots the
defense sees a pattern changes a play
when he changed the play he calls that
out to his teammates that lesson that
general pattern applies to just about
everybody's job and the exciting thing
for me has been to watch Walmart so
Walmart we began training one of their
academies so if walmart has 200 training
academies and basically if you work at
Walmart at any time you can get in your
car drive a few hours and you get to go
and train for a week or so at one of
these academies we started out in one of
them where we put VR there and what we
were training are things like holiday
rush Black Friday where there's people
everywhere running around and
and and yelling at you and it's this
really intense experience giving
employees a sense for what that's going
to be like or having them look around
the store to spot safety violations or
customers who haven't been helped and
the same lessons that we use for
quarterbacks and that first training
academy qualitatively we were finding
that it was a good solution and that
people were enjoying it the training was
working we then went up to 30 training
academies and what we had was 30
training academies use VR and we paired
that with 30 who were not and we could
run a nice controlled experiment to see
the efficacy how well VR worked in terms
of training had really good data there
we're now on all 200 of Walmart's
training academies and to date over a
hundred and fifty thousand employees at
Walmart have put on the virtuality
goggles to get better at their job and
it's a really nice use case training to
help you get better what you do one of
the most useful things about virtual
reality is the tracking data so for a
company who's training someone what we
can do is we can figure out how well
you're learning as you're doing the
behavior we have developed algorithms
such that we can quantify attention and
engagement and how well someone's
encoding a message simply by where
they're looking and how they're turning
their head to make virtual reality work
you have to track all the body movements
and so you know people when they think
of VR most managers they think about the
visual experience aspect of it but in my
opinion the most valuable part of this
from an organizational standpoint is
actually having all this data which is
the richest data in history so if we can
go back to football as an example we
hundreds of thousands of plays watched
over the last couple years by players
every player when they play on the field
they get some level of assessment they
actually get a grade whether even if
they didn't touch the ball later on when
they analyze film every player gets
graded for for many teams we've got the
input data to our machine learning
algorithms which is nonverbal behavior
where they were looking when they
trained in VR and we've got our output
data which is how well they did on the
field and what we can do is build
algorithms that can associate body
movement when training in VR with impact
they had on the field and we've actually
developed a number of features that can
predict if you give somebody a novel set
of body movement during training it can
actually predict how well that person
will perform so the NFL in particular
Troy Vincent who is a vice president of
operations there has been a leader and
they want to be known as the best place
to work and they want to be a leader a
thought leader in this area and so what
we've done for the NFL is we've built a
interview trainer so we talked earlier
about the flight simulator why do you
have a flight simulator because when we
teach people we encourage them to make
mistakes that's how you learn you make
mistake and you get feedback and that's
why we have a flight simulator
interviewing someone should be the same
way so when I interview someone maybe I
asked the wrong question I asked a
different question from person a then
person B based on how that person looked
or maybe I looked in the wrong way or I
leaned in in a way that was what that
was not the right the proper way and
what we've built is an interview
simulator which is extremely realistic
these are very photorealistic avatars
and you go through and you interview
people and you ask questions and we
record your movements we record your
utterances and we give you feedback and
then you repeat it and the National
Football League is using this and at a
number of places the example I'll talk
about is there's something called the
combine in the NFL and the combine is
where players go to you know tryout and
they don't only tryout with our athletic
skills they do interviews to see if
they'd be a good fit
interpersonally on teams and there's
interviews that go on between general
managers and scouts with players and for
a couple of teams we trained their
Scouts and GM's the NFL as an
organization encouraged us to do this so
that they could be better trained on how
to do an interview
[Music]